president biden biden rather his name is
not changed
is setting optimistic new vaccine goals
to fight the coronavirus he now says
anyone who wants a shot may be able to
get one this spring
and that's despite the delays blamed in
part on the trump administration
ed o'keefe has more from the white house
on this story
there's going to be a logistical uh
challenge that exceeds anything we've
ever tried in this country
president biden acknowledged the
difficulties of increasing the rate of
vaccinations across the country
but says his administration should be
able to speed up how quickly americans
get their shots
i think with the grace of god and the
good will of neighbor and the crick not
rising as the old saying goes
i think we may be able to get that to
150
thou 1.5 million a day rather than one
million a day
the president's comments came as he's
faced criticism for suggesting one
million vaccines a day as the initial
distribution target
that's not a big new goal it's exactly
what they inherited from the trump
administration
and operation warp speed the president
also doubled down on his belief that
schools
should be able to reopen sooner rather
than later
i believe we should make
school classrooms safe and secure
for the students for the teachers
and for the the help that's in those
schools
maintaining the facilities but for that
to happen school districts would need
additional federal funding
mr biden is pushing for more school aid
as part of his 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief package
he's already dismissing suggestions by
some democrats and republicans
that the proposal might need to be
scaled down in order to pass
saying he expects negotiations to take
at least a few weeks
this is just a process beginning
meanwhile the president's choice for
treasury secretary janet yellen is set
to begin her first
day on the job the senate confirmed her
last night as the first woman ever
to lead the treasury department his
choice for secretary of state anthony
blinken is expected to be confirmed
later today by the senate
also here at the white house today the
president is expected to use his
executive authorities
to fight racism against asian americans
specifically he's expected to try
to curb anti-asian bias sparked
by the pandemic tony all right ed thank
you very much